alright next game and a nice opponent
here was this Grand Master John none
from from the UK I think it's very well
known especially to the somewhat older
spectator cm it's been a world-class
play and the in the 80s and in the early
90s but pretty much stopped playing a
competitive chess to concentrate on on
writing books editing books and I'm not
quite sure he's involved with this
gambit or it's not every man chance i
think it's gambit i'm not sure but he's
not so much an active player anymore but
of course he knows how to play chess
yeah very much so okay we got some some
real Lopez position where white started
with Don quiet somewhat quiet looking d3
setup but it turned interesting pretty
quickly he opened up the position and
now the question is this is just a
weakness or do I have some some active
play here while telling about nuns
accomplishments I I think I've made some
bad moves okay I need to try to gain
some time here this takes a look at the
a2 porn yeah of course you can play this
anyway but the idea was that have this
move was tempo and then he needs to
worry a bit about this pawn and now the
question is what do I plane now I've got
Roxy for as and as a possibility or
other kinds of moves to maybe sacrifices
porn but
maybe it's bad for me anyway but i'm not
sure what about d 5 i'll just play d5
trying to keep the pony could that you
could play in five of course not sure
how bad this is it takes d5 95 might be
okay looks a bit shaky here okay I
didn't see another move to really keep
keep equality in material terms because
if I if I got 97 we should g7 trying to
put some pressure on e5 Roxy far as an
idea I think taking taking was just
nothing okay but i can i can think about
Roxy for intermediate move but he's got
22 attacking h6o nonsense okay so what
is this position it's got some play of
this lady Fife is not a move I want to
play we can so many light squares should
be should be good can think about Bishop
g7 though it takes on h6 I can take you
five maybe that F form okay what about
Queen to h4 is an idea idea being Roxy
for attacking here double attacking this
Bishop g7 this Bishop is a bit it's not
quite clear what white is doing with
this piece it's just protecting you 5
and this whole configuration of white
would have a knight on f3 it would be
brilliant but I not of course not
because it can take the Queen then but
ok it's trying to try to reroute this
94 light came up soon yeah this is a
problem with this year
okay cannot do without the smooth most
likely ok let's drop back
yeah it's got a nice very nice at 12
chair it takes now I will sacrifice um
porn of course okay I also don't mind
checking this porn maybe this relieves a
bit of the pressure can I take on a two
probably not the idea was that after
bishops and for the moment this Bishop
is not doing so much I take now be three
it's a strap maybe it is trapped
okay if we can just trap the bishop then
it's just bad luck it's very risky
obviously okay it wants to wants to play
for the attack instead which might be a
good idea okay i have six so annoying i
need to get out of this
may be here this looks very shaky when I
need to speed up a bit
yeah looks very dangerous e 6f six
others moves very problematic I'm
morning okay to make some pressure only
six most likely cannot catch you later
anymore here with this time
this is so bad seven of course if this
thing promotes it's bad but if this
bishop may be coming to d5 looxcie 737
f6 might be okay for me maybe okay okay
i have no choice i need to take it's got
rid of the bishop this way rg6 also
what's a problematic
just attacking the rook
defending and attacking 30 seconds on
the clock is a problem ok yeah it's ok
black designs it's ok yeah it's am
obviously difficult to play position
wise i'm not sure rooks III computer
tells me that equal yeah it was
difficult defense and with low time a
sort of pre move drugs e7 no well ok
it's a good player but not so i'm not so
awful to lose but not strictly necessary
now from the position but i got myself
in a bit of trouble here after the
opening talking a bit too much I guess
alright thanks for watching